Speaker 1: All right.
Let's get into what was an insane weekend.
Donald Trump held his first official 2024
rally.
Now, I know the year is 2023.
What I mean is the first rally for his 2024
campaign, and it went bad very quickly.
The location was Waco, Texas.
We should not ignore the significance of on
the 30th anniversary roughly, of the siege
at Waco of the Branch Davidians, that Donald
Trump chose to hold his rally in that very
location.
And in fact, he opened the rally with totally
apocalyptic messaging about how 2024 is the
final battle and using exactly that type of
disastrous imagery that is often associated
with the Waco siege.
Speaker 2: And 2024 is the final battle.
That's going to be the big one.
Is it?
If you put me back in the White House, their
reign will be over and America will be a free
nation once again.
Speaker 1: Again, coming as a surprise to
many of us that America is not currently a
free nation.
Very confusing statement.
Speaker 2: Our enemies are desperate to stop
us because they know that we are the only
ones who can stop them.
They know that.
Speaker 1: Classic and standard fascistic
messaging where I alone can fix it.
Speaker 2: You know, there's never been a
movement like this.
And that's true.
Our country.
That's true in the history of almost every
country.
Let's hope.
Maga make America great again.
America.
First goal, Whatever you want.
But I will tell you, there's never been in
history.
Look at this crowd as far as the eye can see.
We flew over and it was a beautiful sight.
Speaker 1: As far as the eye can see.
Now, the crowd was animated at this early
stage of the very, very long rally, but they
very quickly settled and quieted down, including
when Donald Trump bragged about his passing
a brain injury screening test, which many
people I guess, are not finding as convincing
as maybe they once did.
Speaker 2: I said, should I do it or not?
And I did it.
And you know what?
I used to get them.
All right.
You see, some of them are tough.
And, you know, it was after that it was after
that that nobody called me stupid anymore.
I was right because I never like that narrative.
I don't like the word stupid, but other people
are very stupid.
Speaker 1: He doesn't like the word.
He doesn't like the narrative as applied to
himself, but he'll immediately apply it to
others.
Donald Trump did very aggressively go after
Ron DeSantis.
He even told it wasn't even a sir story.
It was.
He came to me with tears in his eyes.
It's beyond parody at this point.
Speaker 2: Congressman West, that was a good
speech you gave.
But they've been very loyal.
But I'm a loyalist.
And and when a man comes to me, tears in his
eyes, he's had almost nothing in the past.
Speaker 1: It's crazy how many men, big, strong
guys are constantly crying around Trump.
Speaker 2: And he's fighting somebody that
said 42, and he's got almost $30 million in
the bank.
Speaker 1: Yeah, he was crying like a dog.
Speaker 2: That almost nothing.
He's got no cash.
And I said, I can't give you an inducement.
There's no way you can win.
You did.
But he fought a little bit like 150.
He was certainly no Jim Jordan that I can
tell you.
Right.
He fought a little bit just a little bit on
impeachment.
Hoax number one, Impeachment.
Hoax number two, meeting on television, because
I didn't know him very well, but I saw him.
So he came and he really wanted I said, you
can't win, can you Can win, sir.
If you endorse me, I'll win.
Please, Please, sir.
Endorse me, sir.
You're such a good president.
I just need the endorsement.
I'm dead.
And I said, All right, let's give it a shot.
Because honestly, the secretary of Agriculture
and.
Speaker 1: Anyway, so people just bursting
into tears around Trump all the time.
At another very bizarre moment.
Trump claimed that a very famous man recently
asked him how he puts his clothing on.
Speaker 2: Imagine I had a man come up to
me, a very famous man, and almost everybody
probably would have of a businessman.
I saw him about two weeks ago.
He said to me, Can I ask you?
I never liked him very much, to be honest.
But he did say.
He said, speaking for Mr. President, sir,
I'd like to ask you one question.
City.
Speaker 1: Your coffee, sir.
Speaker 2: You take the abuse.
How do you wake up in the morning?
Put on your clothes.
How do you put on a shirt?
Every single day there Is that ever happened
to me, I think.
I wouldn't know what to do.
Speaker 1: Well, we're very proud of the former
president.
He passed a brain injury screening test and
he also dresses himself all by himself every
single day.
And that alone probably makes him qualified
to do something.
I don't know.
Donald Trump with a very a very important
message to women for inclusivity in 2024.
Speaker 2: I never liked Horse Face.
I never like I like it's just not that terrible
for.
That wouldn't be the one, right?
There is no one.
We have a great first lady.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So a very inviting message of Trump's respect
for women there, as you can see, referring,
of course, to Stormy Daniels.
Donald Trump once again playing up this entire
baby bonus thing.
Speaker 2: We will support baby bonus as so
many people like that for the new baby boom
that will be coming.
We need babies.
All of this is.
Speaker 1: We need babies now.
Of course we have a sort of baby bonus already.
It's called a child tax credit.
Democrats and many on the left want to increase
it and make it permanent.
It would be a baby bonus.
It would be an incentive to have children,
which whether you like that or not, it's what
Trump is talking about.
But they don't want to do that.
And much like with NAFTA and USMCA, it seems
Trump's plan is sort of like to get rid of
what we have and replace it with the exact
same thing, but to give it a different name.
Donald Trump continuing the attacks on New
York.
Manhattan D.A.
Alvin Bragg calling New York prosecutors absolute
human scum.
Speaker 2: But the two lead prosecutors, absolute
Yeah.
One, a Hillary Clinton lawyer from a Hillary
Clinton law firm.
Do you.
Speaker 1: Believe?
Does anybody know why they say Clinton?
I mean, Marjorie Taylor GREENE says Clinton,
and she's from the South.
And Trump says Clinton, and he's from Queens.
Is it a deliberate sort of pejorative, sort
of the way some people might say?
Tulsi Gabbard I don't know.
I don't know who would say that.
What is it?
What is it about that?
And then lastly, Trump bringing back the creepy
and on music and bemoaning how airports function.
Speaker 2: Nation where once revered airports
are dirty, they're a crowded mess.
You sit and wait for hours and then are notified
that the plane won't leave and they have no
idea when it will.
Speaker 1: Trump saying this.
Minutes before getting on to his private plane
and taking off and flying directly home.
So not the most relatable moment of the speech.
So dangerous rhetoric.
A semi comatose crowd as the speech went longer
and longer.
You know, you wait all day in the direct sun
with the fetid porta potties and next thing
you know, the speech finally starts and it's
a snoozer.
So I sympathize with the crowd in a sense.
I would not go to one of these things.
But where I want to go next is someone we
know did go to this thing and he stood in
the sun and he got some wild material for
us.
That's Luke Beasley.
Let's talk about
that next.